ah there you are it's time to get up and
go bargain hunting retailers Best Buy
and Game Stop are making new Xbox one
consoles even more attractive this week
at both stores you can get a free copy
of grand theft auto 5 with the purchase
of a new console I'm Lucy and welcome to
this cheapest chips game spot news
updates so not only do you get a copy of
rockstars acclaimed open world game but
also included is a great white shark
cash card which comes with 1.25 million
dollars worth of in-game currency and
this normally sells for 20 bucks on its
own also note that the free GTA 5 offer
is good on any Xbox one system including
bundles that already come with free
games nice to learn more and place an
order head to Best Buy and Game Stop
this offer seems to only work in the
u.s. so sorry international pals in
other news of our GTA 5 the game
continues to sell obscenely well
originally released in September 2013
the game was the number three overall
best-selling game at US retail in
February 2016 so you're gonna hit up Los
Santos with this bargain deal do you
sometimes spell game stop as GameSpot I
know I do let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I'm
ELISA James games for all latest on GTA
5 keeping games for